E aí
[Música]
Olá eu sou o Ronaldo Campos tenho 60
anos mas sou uma pessoa que desde cedo
acreditava que na Bíblia nós precisamos
seguir os nossos valores e que quando
você tem valores fortes dentro de você
nenhuma tempestade do mundo pode te
abater 30 acreditei no universo Generoso
em um mundo de abundância aqui para
conseguir isso era muito importante a
gente valorizar muito estudo e o
trabalho se você nasceu pobre se você
não veio de uma família de grandes
recursos é através do estudo da vontade
de aprender tá curiosidade Sadia que
você pode mudar o teu destino eu não
atendi só estudei em escola pública não
sei o que é estudar em escola particular
mas quando eu tinha os meus 16 anos
naquela época que você tem que escolher
uma profissão e definir o teu futuro
eu coloquei uma meta muito alta mais uma
meta que eu acreditava eu aos 16 anos
disse assim Ronaldo o que você quer da
vida e eu falei eu quero entrar na USP e
só escrever alguns que são Paulo e ainda
quero ganhar um milhão de dólares antes
dos 30 anos foi uma uma pelo que eu fiz
um universo pois bem estudando em escola
conta que fazer um cursinho último ano
eu passei em primeiro lugar na Sudeste
para Odontologia no tempo em que essa
profissão era extremamente concorrida e
não faço estudar mesmo estudando na USP
minha mãe me mandava um salário mínimo
por mês e eu tinha que me virar durante
dois anos eu comi pão com água na hora
do almoço Um Pedaço de Pão um copo de
água e o percebi uma coisa importante
que as dificuldades não surgem no nosso
caminho
o ano se fortalecer e para nos empurrar
para frente eu não podia ficar na sua
reclamando da vida pelo contrário tinha
que aprender acontecer em todos os
estados por tudo aquilo que eu estava
passando eu acho que na vida a gente
precisa vencer sem vitimismo parar de
achar que o governo tem que fazer alguma
coisa parar de esperar que o destino vai
cair no céu uma grande oportunidade a
gente tem que aprender a tomar atitudes
e ao informar a universidade em São
Paulo eu tomei uma atitude muito
importante eu decidi ser empresário eu
montei uma empresa e essa empresa a
gente foi uma empresa de sucesso eu
posso dizer que eu estava no lugar certo
na hora certa no momento certo com as
pessoas certas e tudo deu certo tive uma
carreira profissional uma carreira
empresarial
um sucesso total fiz 4 pós-graduações
bem para minha família tudo aquilo que o
dinheiro pode comprar as melhores
escolas os melhores clubes moravam num
condomínio fechado de classe média-alta
eram a família e sucesso até o momento
em que eu descobri uma coisa dolorosa
que mudou o caminho da minha vida e da
minha história no auge da minha
profissão eu descobri que dos meus
quatro filhos dois tinham usado droga e
um tinha desenvolvido uma doença chamada
dependência química por cocaína E aí eu
falo que eu falei durante três horas sem
parar fazendo aquela pergunta aonde foi
que eu errei e aquela empresa
maravilhosa que eu tinha agora é uma
empresa
e eu ia para um trabalho sem aquela
decisão sem aquela vontade que tinha e
ainda tem que tomar uma outra atitude
uma atitude que mudou novamente a minha
vida porque eu decidi que eu ia fazer
lucro do prejuízo não adiantava mais a
ficar reclamando do meu filho reclamando
da família reclamando do destino eu
tinha um filho na droga eu tinha um
filho que tava indo todo mundo da
criminalidade e um tinha que fazer
alguma coisa e esta alguma coisa era
entender muito em que ele havia se
metido foi aí então eu tomei uma decisão
de criar uma instituição chamada
comunidade terapêutica filhos da luz
para tratar de dependentes químicos
trouxemos dando-lhe uma oportunidade de
tratamento EA cooperação porque eu não
tenho trava só dependente Eu também
pensava
a família dele e aí tomei uma outra
decisão radical e um fechei a minha
empresa abandonei a profissão e me
tornei involuntário em tempo integral
comecei a buscar pessoas macumba eu me
vestia de mendigo Ia para a cracolândia
entrava na Atento tentando tirar as
pessoas desse mundo de dor e sofrimento
e percebi que as obras assistenciais não
podem mais seguir Aquele modelo e dizer
olha me ajuda porque eu sou pobre que eu
preciso da sua caridade Não eu coloquei
uma Visão Empresarial no trabalho dele
eu entendo que as instituições que
cuidam no próximo elas precisam também
ter um modelo diferente porque o sucesso
gente verdadeiro na vida não é apenas o
sucesso econômico sucesso de verdadeira
é sucesso não aqui e no a colar tanto na
dimensão Econômica mas também a dimensão
espiritual que nos
O que levar a vida foi porque nesse
momento eu descobri uma coisa fantástica
que é o conceito de propósito de vida
todos nós nascemos desse mundo para
fazermos uma grande coisa para o próximo
propósito não liberta é a nossa oferta é
a nossa nosso desejo e do alguma coisa e
percebi também que a felicidade completa
dependeria de um conceito novo que é
deixar um legado Qual é o legado que
você prefere deixar para as gerações
futuras eu acho que é uma trajeto você
passar pelo mundo e não deixar um legado
então aqui os dados que a gente estão
aonde eu impressos nos dons talentos e
as minhas YouTube e os meus recursos
financeiros ela desenvolve modelos de
educação que visam mudança de modelo
mental as pessoas usam drogas as pessoas
a depressão as pessoas dentro falando
polistas pessoas se suicidam Por que o
modelo mental dela é um modelo e
imediatista descobrimos na filhos da luz
que quando você dá um propósito de vida
para o próximo falando o trabalho do
dentro do trabalho da caridade do da
ajuda a outro as pessoas melhoram o
mundo melhor então quando você usa seus
dons e talentos para ajudar no próximo
tudo isso tende a se transformar então
na filhos adultos e esse é o nosso
modelo de tratamento ensine as pessoas a
cuidar dos outros ensina as pessoas para
ter um contato maior com a Vontade
Divina e isso é tudo dá certo tanto é
porque você deve estar se perguntando eu
seu filho aquele que usou droga como é
que ficou o meu filho se libertou das
drogas e hoje eu posso dizer para todos
vocês
a química tem solução dependência
química tem um caminho Nossa instituição
também que não conceito louco chamado
surpresa terapêutica nós para ajudarmos
as pessoas precisamos ter tratamento de
um rabo trabalho e moradia E aí então
decidimos que nós vamos buscar a
auto-sustentabilidade toda vez que vemos
uma grande ideia na vida precisamos
também vou ver os meios para se manter
eu realmente acredito gente que uma das
maiores alegrias da vida é a gente
servir a universo começando pela família
mas sem esquecer no próximo o trabalho
bem cura as dores da nossa sala o
trabalho do dengue reconquista e
reconstroem os laços familiares que
foram abaladas ao longo da caminhada
hoje eu sou voluntária
em tempo integral 24 horas sete dias por
semana e não troca essa vida ou nada
porque como eu disse para vocês eu tô
vendo sucesso mas o sucesso se não tiver
um olhar voltado para o próximo pode ser
um sucesso e feio apenas um sucesso
monetário não é isso mais que eu quero
para mim e convido todos a vocês a viver
em um grande propósito de vida a deixar
um novo um legado objetivo para gerações
futuras tornando esse lugar Um lugar
melhor para todos gratidão